Rick is with us in Charleston South
Carolina hi Rick how are you I am
wonderful Dave
God I know you're doing well - yes sir
how can I help my question is what would
Dave do I just recently closed on an
investment property it's a two quad
units on the same parcel this is my
third investment property and the
previous owner had a deal set up with
one of the tenants that he would get
reduced rent and he was also the
property manager he would collect the
rent and deposit it into the previous
owners bank account after a couple of
conversations with the gentlemen I had
that same arrangement with him well he
collected the rent long technically his
rent in the neighbor I had gotten the
other two and he was going to the
positive and then he tells me he got
jumped so he has been unresponsive to me
in text messages calls knocking on the
door the neighbor is telling me that he
did not get jumped and I feel like I'm
being fed a a little tail here so what
would Dave do in this case um well
you're dealing with someone that either
had a crime committed against them or
they're a liar and they're a thief is
that I'm understanding this right yeah
yes well that time he either either did
get jumpy they got mugged and he got the
money stolen which makes me question you
know several things that can happen I
guess in a situation like that to a lot
of people but I wonder about you know
what time of day he's what kind of
judgment he's using and carrying this
kind of money around his pocket or be
he's a complete thief himself and none
of this happened these are the two
options right right and you kind of
believe it's be right now based on what
you're hearing and how do you know he
got jumped if he's been unresponsive to
you you know he got mugged he was
communicating about a little over a week
ago by text message and there's been
unresponsive uh sense why you have any
idea no okay other than you think he
really did this okay
it was a police report filed on the
mugging I have not been able to confirm
that with him okay um do you live near
the property I do okay you need to swing
by and seem in person and here's what I
would do if I owned the property I would
say listen we've got to get to the
bottom of this either something
Horrible's happened to you or you're
trying to pull one on me and so did you
file a police report if he didn't file a
police report he needs to file one
immediately in which case he's committed
a crime if he didn't get jumped because
if he didn't get mugged because now he's
filing a false police report right so
I'm gonna push him to do that I'm gonna
push to push him to get in the corner
here and go listen if you didn't do it
now if at the end of the day you no
longer trust him what you have is an
employee that you is handling money for
you that you don't trust to handle money
for you if you ever let them handle
money again after that point that's on
you in other words if they worked here
and I felt like they had stolen from me
that would be their last day I don't put
up with thieves
and so that would be his last day
collecting rent on my behalf and and
having reduced rent in the apartment he
now has full rent in the apartment and
no longer has the job of collecting rent
if I think he's a thief
or I might just go ahead and evict him
yeah I'm leaning for the eviction side
and I've not I've not gotten counsel yet
on that I've reviewed the contracts but
I'm one that's going to give someone the
benefit of the doubt I think you need
that you meet with him and look into his
eyes and I think you'll know what's
going on don't you yeah and at that
point I think you're going to know what
to do the fact that he's not returning
your texts does not sound good for him
because if regular people got jumped and
stunned you know I was carrying money
for you and it got stolen
everything I'm going to do is be all up
in your business I'm going to return
everything you do because I'm feeling
really bad that your money got stolen
from me
and I'm afraid I'm going to lose my
sweet deal I got over here but if I'm
feeling a little bit of shaming guilty
because I'm actually trying to run a
scam then I'm going to dodge you and so
this doesn't look good for him right
right yeah you're telling me pretty much
what I'm thinking yeah and so I but I'm
like you say giving the benefit
I'm going to meet person in look in
their eyes you can tell so much about
the body language their body language
and their eyes will tell you more what's
going on in the story wheel and if he
sticks to his story and you want to give
him the benefit out I would force him to
file a police report and reminding that
if he files a police report and it's a
false police report that's a criminal
activity so really if he ever wants to
come clean this is the time and then you
decide if you want him to stay as a
tenant if you think he scammed you
there's no decision on whether he
continues to collect rent if you think
you scammed you if that's over but if he
convinces you that he really did get
mugged and you want to just give him the
benefit out and go ahead and go forward
that's fine but if you think he's lying
after meeting with him and you keep
going forward with him collecting rent
that's on you then yeah I'm definitely
going to remove them from from that
responsibility Kent can I I inherited
him as well as the other tenants yeah
can I can I change can I increase his
rent to the others depends on what
you're going trying with him says you
have a six-month deal at a low rent or
do you have a monthly deal you got a
month-to-month you can you can evict him
on the upcoming month or give him notice
yes to move on the upcoming month and
the victim if he doesn't move Anjan
raises rent if you have a six month at a
lower rent then you're stuck with that
if that's the contract that was signed
you got to have an attorney look at that
- no but you probably can read it and
tell big thing is he's probably going to
want to leave because he's ashamed this
is the Dave Ramsey show